Hi, I'm Briana from freeCodeCamp
and today we're going to talk
about the basics of computer hardware.
Computers are made up
of four basic parts:
The Input/Output, CPU,
and Memory.
The Input is what you're
putting into the computer.
Think about mouse, keyboard,
microphone,
any way you're getting
data into the computer.
The Output is what you're
watching on your monitor
or listening to on
your speakers.
These can both be any format
like text, numbers,
videos, images, what-have-you.
It doesn't matter.
The CPU stands for
Central Processing Unit
and that's what we all think of
when we think of a computer.
It's what does the functions.
It's what runs the software.
It manipulates the data.
The Memory is where we
store data and information.
Now the CPU has exclusive
access to this memory.
You can't get to the Memory
from the Input
or from the Output
without the use of the CPU.
So just to review we've got
four basic parts of a computer:
the Input/Output,
CPU, and Memory.